justin is with us in Florida hi Justin
how are you better than I deserve
what's up so I had a question boy just
listen we graduated from residency to
become an orthodontist and I have
student loans that code all just over 1
million dollars you're kidding
and no sir what were you thinking well I
wasn't thinking clearly so I sat down
and calculated my interest rates and my
interest is about fifty eight hundred
dollars a month so my fiance and our
we're trying to decide what's the best
way to try to attack this if we were
this first year able to pay $10,000 a
month I guess there's basically two ways
that we thought of it I can do income
based and my required payment will be
about three thousand dollars and then we
can take the remaining seven thousand
and take it directly at individual loans
or should we cover the interest and then
pay additional monies towards other
loans so what is your income going to
when are you getting married April and
what will you be making is an
orthodontist about 50 okay and what was
she what does she doing what she be
making we actually just opened up an
office and she works at office so she's
not taking me income out of the office
okay um so if you make two hundred fifty
thousand dollars a year why are you only
putting 120 thousand
on your death well I mean the 250 I
calculated pre-tax you know everything
else I mean we're going to put as much
as we you know possibly can on the debt
yes sir I mean and in the years to come
as they you know income goes up we're
hoping to be able to make payments of 20
or 30 or 40 thousand a month I mean
that's what we're yeah what we're what
we're playing for otherwise I'm just up
a creek without a paddle yeah okay I I
think the thing you have to yeah yes I
would it the income based option does
not do away with interest and so
interest is going to be accruing greater
than you're putting in okay so you don't
right you're not making any mathematical
progress by doing the the three and
seven idea but you will make emotional
progress because you'll be able to knock
off some of the smaller ones right right
and God knows you're gonna need some
emotional progress in this process so
and then the the only other commentary I
would just add is that this is such an
extreme situation your income is extreme
and your debt is extreme that you have
to be very very careful to just act like
you're a broke college student because
you are a broken orthodontist right and
so that means you guys aren't going on
vacations they're not buying a house
you're not leasing a new BMW you're not
going to a restaurant you are you
million I came said out loud my can't
breathe
a million dollars instead it gives me an
anxiety attack and it's not even my dad
um but the the horrible news is that
ridiculous figure the wonderful news is
you have great income potential and a
great income right
so you cannot relax right so you have to
cut as deeply as you can cut right and
so be dialing your taxes in I don't want
you to get behind on taxes but other
than taxes and food and water and
electricity I really want everything
else just going on student loan debt
mm-hmm
this is 250 gross sales in your new
office so you know like I said I just
graduated in this year so I work
part-time for another north adonis to
have a steady income and the office that
my fiance and I worked in we just opened
two months ago so that you know the
income is just steadily increasing on
that right but I'm seeing as I'm asking
the the 250,000 how much of that's from
the new office and how much is from the
old the orthodontist gig about 200 of
that is from me working at another an
orthodontist well I still work three
days a week and then I work in my office
three days a week so I work six days out
right now okay that's good that's good
so we ought to be able to turn that 50
into 250 oh yeah yeah overtime as you
build your clients you know and so forth
okay and okay okay cuz you have a set
interest rate and a set amount of
principal you have to pay but you have
to pay both and so not paying one and
paying more on the other is just hiding
the P under a different shell okay the
only the only benefit of doing the
income-based is because your interest is
probably close to five thousand a month
oh it is that that's the actual interest
rate okay and so yeah and so let's
pretend that you paid the income-based
at three thousand so somewhere another
two thousand eight hundred is landing on
the books as increased balance right
right and then you're reducing
other balances by seven principle and
interest on the smaller ones and so like
I say we're just moving the P around
under a different shell but it will give
you the benefit of getting to check off
some of these smaller ones
what is your smallest one I mean I have
a consolidation that's like eight
hundred but most of this small AB maybe
half a dozen small ones that are 4,500
or less yeah and say you're going to
knock those out like one a month to a
month that kind of thing and for the
first a little while and you know then
we're gonna get down to the big the big
mama-jama the 800 mm-hmm and then it's
going to slow way down in terms of the
emotional benefit and it'll be very
simple to do the calculation but you're
gonna cruise fifty eight hundred dollars
worth of interest somewhere and you are
going to reduce principle by 4200
somewhere in total by using ten thousand
dollars so it doesn't matter the only
benefit is just to be able to check
those little I like just like like I
like cleaning up the little ones getting
the dust out of the corner getting rid
of the mosquitoes and then we'll get
down to the bear hunt because you go
from mosquitos to bears pretty quick
here and so that's overwhelming but you
you the good news is you've got a great
shovel and you have a great bright
future with your income potential and
you know that gets you out of this it's
not a reason to get into it but it does
get you out of it it gives you hope for
your future thank you for the call open
phones a triple eight eight two five
five two two five so if you are worried
about your twelve thousand dollars in
student loan debt
that guy was for you today a million
dollars in student loan debt insured by
you and I
we're the taxpayers we insured that loan
against default I think he's gonna make
it I hope he makes it
I want him to win but on a cultural
level on a policy level the fact that we
have a system in place that would even
allow that to occur that Congress has
put in place a system that allows that
to occur for you and I to guarantee his
student loans is about as asinine as
anything I've ever heard